les attaques et la façon dont elles ont
eu lieu contre great attenberg sont le
symptôme est
d'une société qui y compris dans parmi
les ses élites à une pensée relativement
étriqués dans un cadre très restreint
qui ne supporte pas d'être bousculé
[Musique]
brita sundberg a été attaqué sur quoi
principalement en france n'a pas été
attaquée sur son discours de fond parce
que son discours de fond elle ne fait
que que transmettre la parole des
scientifiques elle vulgarise great
attenberg ne fait aucune exagération
elle ne fait que que transmettre une
parole donnée donc en face nous avons
des notamment des élites qui vont être
dans le déni et qui vont l'attaquer sur
ce qu'elle est intrinsèquement et donc
et ça montre bien encore une fois à quel
point la différence et pathologistes
dans notre société parce que sous
prétexte qu'elle est dans le spectre de
l'autisme ça voudrait dire qu'elle
serait incapable de penser par elle-même
ça voudrait dire qu'elle serait
incapable d'émotion qu'elle serait que
j'ai entendu encore un cyborg etc etc et
donc on voit bien à quel point elle
hystérise tout une toute une classe
d'élite qui sont le produit de cette
société extrêmement normative et ça ça
montre bien l'accueil qu'on fait encore
à 7
ce qui relève de la différence quand on
voit la façon dont elle est
décrédibilisé par rapport au fait
qu'elle est autiste
ça incite très peu les personnes à
vouloir se faire identifier diagnostic
et c'est parce qu'une fois vous êtes
identifié dans cette étiquette là et
bien en effet vous allez être considérée
comme n'étant pas crédible comme étant
instable comme étant incapable d'avoir
une pensée raisonnée ou raisonnable et
or c'est bien ça le problème
hors jeu je vois que great attenberg
même si elle peut agir avec une certaine
passion mais pourquoi pas je vois que
ceux qui la critiquent fin l'hystérie
est davantage dans le camp de 2,7 à ceux
qui la critiquent ça bouge doucement
aujourd'hui le politique a enfin compris
que c'était plus possible en tout cas de
ne pas en parler
donc on parle beaucoup de sociétés
inclusives mais maintenant il y à des
schémas culturels qui sont très très
lent à bouger que ce soit au sein de
l'éducation nationale ou de l'emploi
mais ça bouge doucement bon le problème
principal c'est que dans les dispositifs
pour la société inclusive que nous qui
sont en train d'être mis en oeuvre
il y a encore ce logiciel culturel de
pathologisation la différence on est
dans l'état d'esprit où on pense que
c'est un autiste de changer s'il
autistes ou le dyslexiques ou que
sais-je n'est pas ta correspondre à
l'idée arbitraire qu'on a de la norme
on va lui refuser l'accès est donc là ce
qu'on demande à ces personnes
aujourd'hui c'est une énergie
phénoménale pour pouvoir rentrer dans un
moule et ne surtout pas ressembler à ce
qu'ils sont il ya ne pas se trahir que
ce soit même dans des gestuelles ou des
façons des trous mais sauf que on ne
peut pas tenir un rôle indéfiniment et
même sur des manières d
sous même sur le court terme un rôle qui
ne correspond pas j'espère qu'un jour un
personne pourra s'exprimer de façon
médiatique
même si elle est ouvertement autistes ou
dyslexique et cas ne sera plus attaqué
sur ce qu'elle est j'espère qu'un jour
que ça pourra ça pourrait arriver en
tout cas c'est mon souhait parce que ça
pour vrai ça permettrait aussi à mon
avis de libérer beaucoup de paroles et
beaucoup d'intelligence dont on a
vraiment besoin aujourd'hui